stuffed animals continue to be my score
50 cents a pop Dumbo Disney Store
Snuffaluffagus bang Olaf what and this
one's going to be a beast the FAO
Schwartz giraffe this is gonna be a good
one can I see the giraffe
no no it's not why not because it just
isn't just look at the face that one
looks sadder than the other one no look
at the patches on the eyes like it's not
the one that's gonna be it I may not be
it either
weird it's just Toys R Us it does yeah
so it is the FAO Schwarz Jeffrey it's
Jeffrey wow it's the 30 one just looked
it up Toys R Us FAO Schwarz combo 30
bucks paid 50 cents to say after eBay
fees just like a quick 20 bucks that's
just one of the things wait till I look
up the snuffle others that's such a
great line